ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
video sono stati già oggi siamo stati
sulla mia cameretta di haydn lo humor
game che col gioco dove deve indovinare
cosa è meno popolare rispetto all'altra
concede vinto vi sentite giochiamo e
basta dove ragazzi provo con telefono
perché credo sia molto più aggiornato
della versione del sito quindi la prima
volta che lo gioca col telefono dopo un
miliardo di volte che ho fatto video
sulla girl over ma oggi vediamo dove
riusciamo ad arrivare ragazzi come devo
stabilire un nuovo record che sono solo
bale spero almeno 30 poi vediamo sant
antonio spurs contro new york giants ii
secolo sport guarda qua saranno proprio
new york giants madonna come sono bravo
nello sport secondo me siamo partiti
male però recuperato un upset che a
45.000 madonna ma in così tanti usano
crows marcia tra gran torino e ray
charles ray charles dai e ci sono andato
pensavo molto di più milano milano
milano 3 milioni e mezzo sta mente
milano figura di microsoft più di milano
sarà almeno 12 milioni almeno solo porca
vacca microsoft contro l'orlando orlando
magic e ragazzi basta sport vi prego
togliamolo dalla lo sport non lo voglio
vedere non so capace io non me ne
intendo antidepressivi o di questo me ne
intendo facciamo la roba fatta avanti
depressi mister o meno degli orlando
magic
[Musica]
ma vi guardate le partite degli orlando
me
sicuramente che poi non sono anche se
una squadra magari una marca però banana
cake ma penso meno degli antidepressivi
certo mangiamo agli antidepressivi
violino banana cake violino secondo me
di più giustamente perché gli ovini sono
molto commestibili voi non lo sapete
apple watch sarà almeno 3 milioni almeno
quattro porca vacca fantastico la dyson
questa è una specie di aspirapolvere
credo che sarà di chiusa la meno 10
milioni
non è che alle altre persone non gliene
frega un cazzo è che io sono germi
fonico e pulisco per terra tra pokémon
porca vacca poiché mondo 20 milioni ha
fatto e chicago bulls lav e pokemon
godere madonna e così tanto cercato
perché non può ancora essere floyd
mayweather ma mail weather un milione
due milioni per terra cotta uova ricorsi
o meno perfetto the secret
cos'è di più ma va bene va bene
perfetto bunt far cosa la birra budvar e
una birra ma sei una birra immagino di
più non è una birra penso fosse una
marca di birra io non me ne intendo non
sono il secolo sport non bevono cosa
cattivo affare più avanti dottori senza
frontiere o il display a risplendere
porca vacca foto questa è una razza di
cani ma
meno tra bobo e kevin durant e di più
grande perché lo trovi sia prima dopo
che durante allora mettetevi delle cose
che sono ragazzi vi prego che siano
semplici da pronunciare solo facciate
figura di cacca le faccio io perché
faccio io e video io credo di più
madonna mia le cartelle le caramelle e
pompei più lipari per la a tutti i
ragazzi rolex
sicuramente sarà di più di sicuro non lo
cerco io bravi di quelli che sono i
soldi
qui in vittoria regina vittoria di meno
li meno integrità ma non andò bene oggi
cioè il rata record e trenta ragazzi no
29 nicolò fatto 29
non lo so meno meno c'azzecca barrena
rom a roma aveva beh da oggi vi volete
malissimo sono in realtà di meno perché
non so come si pronunci quindi non so
neanche se la gente lo sa scrivere qui
nell solo io non so scrivere a dunkerque
innsbruck jackson ball jackson perché la
dan curtis mamma mia si cercano solo
find my phone avrà 40 milioni di
ricerche scommettete so io lo perdono
telefono save the children di più bp
anche per il culo ragazzi che abbiamo
categoria perché vedo che ci sono altre
categorie visto che aggiornatissimo
quello della apple rispetto al sito
facciamo tipo gamers quindi solo le
persone famose ad esempio mary cleary e
barbara stanwyck meriti ri ronaldigno
mammamia sulle persone famosa ragazzi
arrivo a 800 vado avanti senza una fine
ve lo giuro
darlene love
meno ok spiderman di più nel famosissimo
non è famoso spider pork meno storga
buttana maggie simpson ma perché maggie
simpson secondo me potrebbe essere
fuorviante
secondo me è molto meno di borgo però
facciamo più perché io so l'eco guarda
avrei lanciato il telefono ma l'ho
pagato quindi non lo lanciamo per l'amor
di dio io dico le robe poi faccio altro
ma anche delle verifiche era questa
infatti prendevo sempre due non ne sono
mai uscito però jeff bridges o chris
brown chris brown tom new york di meno
jonsi wars di più certo john silver
bravo l'ellepì più bravo per sofia
vergara di più
mammamia meno male tavoleto vegan
all'inizio sofia vegana vò ce vò come li
vuoi che sia a sofia ed è vegana bene
con data riporta marmellata livorno a
dipiù milione e mezzo weil giovanna
d'arco
ecco giovanna d'arco secondo me è di
meno però a logica dovrebbe essere a
logiche io metterei di più perché tutti
cerca un giorno ad arco che non ho parte
delle ricercano prodi meno i fatti però
strano perché teoricamente ci sono un
sacco di tipo chi studia storia dovrebbe
cercare ogni tre secondi prof
nigel mansell manselli più ford col
demonio lo vedi che non sono solo io che
non seguo le sport poco tipo non lo
seguo nessuno sigmund freud o robert de
niro sigmund freud era veramente troppe
lo so che robert grande e ben affleck di
più javier bardem di meno non so chi sia
ma va bene
[Musica]
meno più bene
non sto per niente andando a fortuna li
conosco tutti i ragazzi ve lo giuro li
conosco tutti quelli che sto cliccandovi
conosco su chiari lo conosco davvero un
milione ottocento ma pensavo molto di
più
robbie keane catlin jenner guarda non la
conosco ma rimediamo innanzitutto e poi
secondo me di più giusto perché kevin
bacon di più non come kevin bacon 368
come ragazzi non avrò mai kristen
stewart charles dickens meno dai
proviamo l'ultimo rush sui famosi e poi
provoli l'ultima sull'ultima categoria
joe cocker di meno ma andata benissimo e
kanye west di più
madonna chiedevo essere 4 milioni che
vipers rais meno kharkov e gli più
sicuro
nadal avrà quei 4 milioni un milione
solo nadal sta scherzando the frisky
meno jeff ponti la pantera rosa di più
immagini non va bene john travolta molto
di più ok greta garbo mazza sera
cretamente mettevo molto di pi invece
meno per kelly di più ma porco va bene
dai cambiamo ragazzi abbiamo big
question and games che sono le ultime
due categorie di ai ragazzi di provarne
una in game seguono i big questo che è
completamente nuova b questione facciamo
games prima giochi più famosi degli
altri quando ray essere un maestro poi
pagare il prossimo bisogno lo facciamo
tutto dedicato ai giochi super stardust
leaf easier a ci sono anche di youtube
penso di più bravo ragazzo
final fantasy di più bravo final fantasy
colecovision mio dio di meno non sono
anche club sia la summer wars spero di
il nostro nome di meno
porca vacca ci avevo creduto
l'idea di provare l'ultima ma non meno
importante big questions che è una cosa
completamente nuova ci sono le domande
che la gente cerca su google questo
ancora meglio
mai visto per esempio jones non è morto
33mila ricerche oppure è normale fare
tanta cacca
secondo me è normale fare tanta carica
cercato di tipo io di macro che non me
ne intendo
perché così tante celebrità stanno
morendo nel 2016 oppure come diminuire
il grasso sulla pancia
sembra che interessi molto ripido la
celebrità gli alieni sono reali di meno
prima la linea poi gli alieni a che ora
finisce la colazione da mcdonald's ma
cosa ma perché meno per febbre
pioverà oggi alexa troverà oggi questa
sera non è prevista pioggia che bello
che ora oggi avrà tipo con le 400.000
ricerche di 246 va bene quando c'è
presta il media o mio dio meno va bene
come vincere alla lotteria scommetto di
più sicuramente se qualcuno sa vincere
alla lotteria eccetera mese ci fosse
veramente un modulo troveresti scritto
su internet tv how con l'hong tax su di
sé che non so cosa voglia dire di più
però cerco cosa voglio dire
[Musica]